All right, so you might ask,
get ready Megan,
you might ask what does this
have to do with vision?
>> What does this have
to do with vision?
>> Well you might have some video
of something happening such as
a person moving their hands around to
wave, or point, or control something.
And you'd like to be able to say,
you know, which gesture is this?
Or you know, what action are they doing?
And the stuff I'm going to talk about
today is sort of some of this time
series work,
in particular Markov models,
apply to the decoding of
visual kinds of information.
So the real question is,
how do we model these problem?
How do we, you know, how are we going to
build, I showed you these time series.
Well, we need a model of these.
And in particular, we're going to
have to give it a bunch of them to
be able to construct that model.
So it's basically going to be
an inference or a learning problem.
The learning is, learning the model and
the inferences while
given a set of models,
which one do I think is most likely to
have generated the data that I'm seeing?